nous allons examiner nos progrès pour ce
qui est de renforcer le dispositif de
dissuasion et de dépenses de l'OTAN nous
allons renforcer davantage la protection
de nos infrastructures essentielles à la
lumière du sabotage des pipelines et
nous allons maintenir et intensifier
notre soutien envers du crâne
afin que nous puissions afin que les
Ukrainiens puissent continuer à se
défendre et à libérer leur territoire de
l'occupation russe
à l'initiative et elle multiplie les
avancées significatives sur le terrain
alors que la Russie se livre de plus en
plus à des attaques horrifiques et sans
discrimination contre les civils et les
infrastructures critiques
le président Poutine est en train
d'échouer en Ukraine
ces tentatives annexion
la mobilisation partielle et son
discours dangereux sur le nucléaire
constitue la plus grande d'escalade
depuis le début de l'invasion
[Musique]
que pour lui la guerre ne se passe pas
comme prévu
l'OTAN n'est pas parti au conflit mais
notre soutien joue un rôle clé
pour soutenir la souveraineté et la
légitime défense de l'Ukraine
le ministre de la défense de l'Ukraine
se joindra à nous demain
et pour le dîner avec les ministres des
pays de l'OTAN ensemble nous examinerons
les besoins urgents du pays
et je me félicite des annonces récentes
de la mise à disposition par les alliés
de systèmes de pointes de défense
aérienne ainsi que d'autres capacités et
je serai et j'attends d'autres annonces
notre message est clair
l'OTAN restera solidaire avec l'Ukraine
jusqu'au bout
le président Poutine qui a commencé la
guerre et c'est lui qui doit y mettre
fin en retirant ses forces de l'Ukraine
et le président
mettre fin à la complicité de la
Biélorussie
dans ce conflit illégal
je dis je présiderai une séance
ordinaire du groupe des plans nucléaires
l'objet fondamental de notre capacité
nucléaire de tous les temps
cela a été de préserver la paix
t'empêcher la coercition et de dissuader
l'agression la semaine prochaine
l'automne organise son exercice
dissuasion c'était face nous programmée
depuis longtemps déjà il s'agit d'un
entraînement de routine qui intervient
chaque année et qui est destiné à
assurer la sécurité la sûreté et
l'efficacité de notre dissuasif
les menaces nucléaires à peine voilées
du président Poutine sont dangereuses et
irresponsables la Russie c'est
pertinemment qu'on ne gagnera jamais une
guerre nucléaire et qu'il ne faut jamais
mener une guerre nucléaire
nous surveillons de près les forces
nucléaires de la Russie et nous n'avons
pas constaté d'évolution de la posture
russe mais nous restons vigilants
nous dirigeons ont décidé une évolution
fondamentale de notre dispositif de
défense et de dissuasion afin de faire
face à la nouvelle donne sécurité nous
avons doublé le nombre de groupes
antiques de l'OTAN à l'est de l'Alliance
ils peuvent rapidement monter en
puissance pour atteindre le niveau de
brigade et nous relevons aussi le nombre
de nos forces à haut niveau de
préparation
à la présente ministérielle nous allons
prendre des décisions afin d'augmenter
nos stocks de munitions et de matériel
cela afin d'accélérer la mise à
disposition de capacités et afin de
profiter du processus de planification
de la Défense de l'OTAN pour donner aux
industriels une demande de plus pérenne
afin qu'ils intensifient la production
nous parlerons également de la
protection de nos infrastructures
essentielles
l'OTAN est à l'oeuvre là-dessus depuis
des années
et après le sabotage des pipelines nos
stream
nous vous avons redoublé de vigilance
dans tous les domaines
nous avons doublé notamment notre
présence en mer Baltique et en mer du
Nord elle passe à plus de 30 bâtiments
qui sont accompagnés par des avions de
patrouille maritime des Batma et par des
capacités sous-marines
le commandement maritime de l'OTAN même
ses efforts en étroite coordination
autour des installations clés aussi ils
intensifie le partage d'éléments de
renseignement et la collecte d'éléments
de renseignement et nous prendrons
d'autres mesures afin de renforcer notre
résilience et de protéger nos offres
futures essentielles
tout attaque
délibéré contre les infrastructures
essentielles des alliés
suivi d'une réaction résolue et punie
notre dernière séance c'est
ministérielle portera sur les missions
et les opérations de l'OTAN du Kosovo à
l'Irak
à nous parce que l'OTAN ait lieu font
face aux mêmes défis de sécurité
cet hiver sera rude d'où la grande
importance puisque jamais pour
l'Amérique du Nord et l'Europe de rester
unis pour soutenir l'Ukraine et pour
défendre nos populations là-dessus
j'attends vos questions
nous commençons par le haut de la salle
Dodge
Monsieur le Secrétaire général
vous disiez que vous prendriez des
décisions lors de cette réunion quand au
renforcement des stocks de munitions
nationaux vous avez parlé des arsenaux
tout en fournissant l'Ukraine mais pour
ce qui est des systèmes en théoriens
envoyés par l'Allemagne normalement
l'Allemagne devait faire cette commande
pour elle-même l'Estonie employée tout
un convoi de Javelin à l'Ukraine est-ce
que cela vous préoccupe les allées
fournissent tout ce qu'ils peuvent à
l'Ukraine mais cela signifie qu'ils sont
vulnérables eux-mêmes qu'est-ce qui
ressortira de cette réunion dans ce
contexte là
à l'Ukraine
ses capacités des armes des munitions
différents types de soutien donc nous le
saluons et nous l'avons encouragé du
côté de l'OTAN des
débuts de l'invasion
d'ailleurs nous avions commencé à
moi-même l'impatience rappelons-nous que
les Alliés appuient l'Ukraine depuis
2014 y compris par l'entraînement de
dixième de milliers de soldats et
d'officiers Ukrainiens qui maintenant
joue un rôle essentiel face à cette
agression riche de l'Ukraine après
l’impression clairement cette tête c'est
renforcée le soutien offert par les
alliés de l'OTAN vous parlez des Javelin
des systèmes de défense entière les
munitions et bien tout cela est retiré
de stock existant en effet donc en se
faisant leur stock se sont amenés ceci
dit c'était la bonne décision apprendre
en effet il est important pour chacun
d'entre nous que l'Ukraine gagne cette
guerre
face aux forces
en effet si le président Poutine devait
gagner cela serait un échec pour les
Ukrainiens mais ce serait aussi un échec
et en danger pour chacun d'entre nous en
effet
cela ferait de notre monde à mon plus
dangereux et cela nous rendrait plus
vulnérables face à d'éventuelles autres
agression russe c'est pour cette raison
que nous avons utilisé les stocks de
l'OTAN les stocks des pays alliés de
l'OTAN pour appuyer l'Ukraine bien
entendu cependant plus cette guerre
il sera important de
renforcer ces stocks de les
réapprovisionner c'est pour cette raison
que nous soulevons maintenant cette
question comment renforcer la production
il s'agit de produire davantage pour
réapprovisionner les stocks et continuer
à soutenir le crâne ce matin à ce que
les ministres d'ailleurs prennent des
décisions lors de la ministérielle
demain et après-demain sur ces questions
comment utiliser le processus de
planification Défense de l'OTAN pour se
mettre d'accord sur des objectifs plus
ambitieux
je pense notamment à différentes
capacités
notamment et l'augmentation éventuelle
des objectifs et des orientations en
tout cas pour ni pour les stocks cela
fournirait à l'industrie une demande
plus pérenne à long terme pour qu'ils
puissent investir dans des capacités de
production supplémentaire ainsi la
production sera renforcée
ils pourront utiliser les capacités de
production
existantes davantage et aussi lancer de
nouveaux investissements je m'attends à
ce que les ministres s'accordent aussi
sur la façon dont nous pouvons renforcer
notre interopérabilité davantage comment
délier à ce que les Alliés puissent
travailler ensemble et puis c'est aussi
acquérir
ensemble des capacités des munitions il
s'agira donc de bien gérer les stocks
éveillés aussi à cette interopérabilité
entre alliés
je pense que c'est le meilleur
instrument pour veiller à ce que les
Alliés ce corps donnent et fournissent à
long terme ce message de demande à
l'industrie
question
qui porte sur l'infrastructure
pendant le week-end cela empêché
d'imiter les transports dans le nord du
pays nous avons vu également les fuites
sur le Gazo du Nord Stream qui est
normalement approvisionne l'Allemagne en
tout cas va jusqu'en Allemagne dans
quelle mesure est-ce que ces incidents
sont-ils des actes de guerre et en quoi
est-ce que l'OTAN peut répondre c'est
une alliance collective vous avez dit
que les Alliés répondrai comment
envisagez-vous de réagir dans ce
contexte
ces dernières années
lancer sa transformation la plus
importante de la défense collective
depuis la fin de la guerre froide dans
ce contexte il s'agit de prendre en
compte les menaces hybrides et celles il
y a quelques années nous avions bien dit
que les attaques hybrides pourraient
relever de l'article 5 pourrait
représenter une attaque armée contre
l'alliance nous avons donc renforcé
notre travail sur la résilience et donc
la protection des infrastructures
essentielles tout en lançant davantage
d'exercices sur les menaces hybrides
cyber et nous échangeons de meilleures
pratiques nous nous sommes aussi mis
d'accord sur des orientations qui
concernent la protection des
infrastructures essentielles il s'agit
donc de protéger notamment les capacités
sous-marines des infrastructures telles
que des gazeux des câbles mais je pense
aussi ici au réseau électrique
l'infrastructure qui permet le transport
énergétique je ne peux pas faire de
commentaires sur ces incidents
spécifiques des enquêtes sont en cours
nous devons attendre les résultats de
ces enquêtes avant de porter un
quelconque jugement mais de façon
générale je peux vous dire que nous
suivons de très près tout incident qui
pourrait être une attaque cyber ou
hybride contre les alliés de l'OTAN nous
nous tenons prêts à prendre les mesures
nécessaires si cela devait s'avérer
utile le type de mesure dépend de la
nature de l'attaque qui ne donneront
jamais à notre adverse c'est potentiel
le privilège de comprendre exactement où
se situe le seuil de déclenchement de
l'article 5 c'est une décision que nous
prendrons en tant qu'allié tout en
prenant en compte le contexte exact la
situation précise à laquelle nous
serions confrontés s'il devait une
attaque hybride aussi vers question
interfaces secrètes
merci
général
d'après les États-Unis et l'Ukraine les
frappes d'hier contre l'Ukraine était
planifié en a mon avait rien à voir avec
le pont de Kerch comme le disent les
Russes de plus certains analyses ont
indiqué que l'Ukraine n'avait rien à
voir avec l'incident du pont de catch
apparemment ce n'est qu'un prétexte
est-ce que le temps partage cette
évaluation
pensez-vous que nous sommes en tournant
de cette guerre qu'est-ce que cela
pourrait changer sur le terrain sur le
champ de bataille et puis pour rebondir
sur la question qu'il a été posée vous
avez indiqué que les ministres
discuteraient des stocks et de leur
réapprovisionnement demain mais la
guerre dure depuis 7 mois déjà pourquoi
est-ce que cette question n'a pas été
soulevée sous un amant réponse
[Musique]
a déjà commencé pareil avec les
différents alliés nous avons déjà
commencé de discuter de la façon dont
nous pouvons réapprovisionner les stocks
nous avons d'ailleurs une réunion avec
les directeurs de l'armement de l'OTAN
il y a quelques semaines de cela ici à
l'OTAN c'est donc un travail qui est en
cours par contre lorsque les ministres
se réuniront demain ce sera une
opportunité supplémentaire qui permettra
de voir où nous en sommes quels ont été
nos avancées en matière de renforcement
de la production et cela nous permettra
aussi de prendre de nouvelles décisions
pour veiller à ce que non seulement nous
utilisons les stocks existants pour
assister l'Ukraine mais que nous
puissions aussi accélérer la production
notamment de munitions et dames c'est
nécessaire pour veiller à la dissuasion
et à la défense de nos alliés mais aussi
pour continuer pour poursuivre sur le
long terme cette appui à l'Ukraine pour
éviter toute mauvaise interprétation ce
travail ne vient pas de commencer il a
été commencé il y a bien il a été lancé
il y a bien longtemps mais plus cette
guerre dure plus ce travail avec
l'industrie prendra de l'importance en
effet ils auront besoin de décision il
auront besoin des décisions liées au
processus de planifieration de Défense
de l'OTAN pour lancer les
investissements nécessaires et ainsi
produire davantage maintenant
posiez la question de savoir comment les
attaques d'hier pouvaient changer la
situation sur le champ de bataille moi
je pense que les incidents d'hier sont
un signe de faiblesse la réalité c'est
qu'il n'arrive pas à avancer sur le
champ de bataille de la Russie perd sur
le champ de bataille il perdent des
territoires tout simplement parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les capacités pour
pêcher les forces ukrainiennes d'avancer
leur réponse c'est donc de lancer des
attaques indiscriminées contre des
villes ukrainiennes ils ont frappé des
cibles civiles des infrastructures
essentielles
la conséquence de cela c'est bien
entendu de la souffrance et des dommages
en Ukraine mais cela ne fait que
refléter le manque d'alternative qui
s'offre au président ils perdent du
terrain ils n'ont plus l'initiative et
donc ils ont dû en venir à des frappes
de missiles à des frappes aériennes
comme celles que nous avons pu observer
hier et aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
votre première question qu'elle était
elle
lancer des attaques similaires en début
de la guerre
mais il y en a eu contre Kiev et contre
l'ouest du pays
de l'Ukraine ce sont des frappes qui ont
été exécutées assez régulièrement
après ce que ça avait été prévu planifié
ces frappe aussi je ne ferai pas de
commentaires mais c'était en tout cas
des attaques entre des villes des civils
ont été tués des infrastructures civiles
sont ciblées par ces attaques c'est
inacceptable
et c'est en violation du droit
international financials questions
merci beaucoup j'espère te poser une
question sur l'exercice nucléaire
entre les 30 alliers est-ce que l'on
s'était interrogés sur l'opportunité
d'organiser un exercice
d'arme nucléaire étant donné le niveau
élevé de la menace côté russe c'est le
risque de terreur de calcul et est-ce
que la nature de l'exercice de cette
année serait différente étant donné le
contexte très important je sais bien
qu'il s'agit d'un exercice de routine
annuel c'est bien compris mais entre
alliés
c'est ton interrogé sur le timing de
l'exercice
de fermeté et de bien montrer que l'OTAN
existe pour défendre tous les alliés cet
exercice est programmé depuis longtemps
depuis même avant l'invasion de
l'Ukraine il s'agit d'un exercice
routine destiné à la sûreté la sécurité
et l'efficacité de notre dissuasif
militaire
j'ai pu assister cet exercice il y a
quelques années de cela
nous avons toujours fait preuve
d'ouverture à l'égard d'exercice et ce
serait envoyé à mauvais signal c'est
subitement ne devions annuler un
exercice de routine programmé depuis
longtemps à cause de la guerre en
Ukraine voilà qui serait tout à fait le
mauvais message
un véhiculé et il faut bien reconnaître
et prévisible et notre puissance
militaire
et prévenir et tout attaque contre un
pays membres de l'Alliance
ici nous devions
la possibilité de se méprendre sur notre
volonté de défendre nos alliés voilà qui
accentuerait le risque d'escalade et
c'est ce que nous souhaitons surtout
éviter la radio polonaise
divers hommes politiques dans différents
États membres
laissent entendre que à la lumière et
des attaques d'hier et d'aujourd'hui qui
tue des civils et qui cible les
infrastructures le moment est venu de
désigner la Russie comme étant un état
terroriste allez vous qualifier la
Russie d'État terroristes il est
également question de la tenue d'un
sommet des chefs d'État et de
gouvernement des pays de l'OTAN est-ce
qu'un sommet est prévu réponse ne
consultons sans cesse les alliés de
l'automne nous avons déjà organisé trois
sommets de l'OTAN cette année et nous
allons convoquer des sommets quand le
besoin à s'en fait sentir
constamment l'opportunité d'organiser
afin de pouvoir mener sereinement les
consultations voulues
à tous les niveaux voilà nous savons une
mystérieuse cette semaine qui sera déjà
une possibilité de communiquer les
messages voulus et nous allons prononcer
nous prononcer sur l'éventualité
d'organiser un sommet
quand nous jugerons le moment opportun
ensuite sur la nature de la guerre il
s'agit
une invasion illégale d'un autre État
soit une violation flagrante du droit
international
la Russie a envahi un pays souverain et
indépendant en violence à souveraineté
et c'est son intégrité territoriale
mais tout cela n'a pas commencé en 2022
en février il faut remonter à 2014
mais la Russie a intensifier ses actes
d'agression contre l'Ukraine en février
et la Russie a violé le droit
international de manière flagrante et
nous avons vu des attaques horrifiques
contre des civils
nous avons vu les informations de
boutcha et d'autres endroits en Ukraine
l'essentiel à l'heure actuelle c'est de
disposer de tous les faits de pouvoir
mener les enquêtes nécessaires et l'OTAN
soutien à ses enquêtes j'ai déjà lancé
il est important que les responsable
soit traduits en justice et tenue
responsables pour ces atrocités
le pont de Kirch est-il une cible
militaire légitime à vos yeux
de théorie
ensuite vous avez parlé d'intensifier le
soutien au profit de l'Ukraine et vous
avez évoqué des systèmes de défense
aérienne quelles autres systèmes d'armes
l'Ukraine doit-elle recevoir qu'elle n'a
pas reçu et dont elle a besoin pour
faire face à la situation actuelle
réponse
Ukraine a besoin de divers systèmes
létale de véhicules blindés de système
d'artillerie et de défense
anti-aérienne ainsi que
et beaucoup d'autres
éléments de matériels
[Musique]
pour nous de nous retrouver demain au
sein du groupe de contact
organisé par les États-Unis et entre le
ministre de la Défense des pays de
l'OTAN avec le ministre Reznikov nous
aurons
une belle occasion afin de de confronter
les listes des besoins de l'Ukraine et
les systèmes que les alliés peuvent
mettre à disposition
cette consultation c'est poursuit depuis
des mois déjà et c'est ce qui nous a
permis de mobiliser un tel soutien de la
part des alliés et des partenaires de
l'otanos
aérienne mais j'ai bien d'autres
capacités aussi par exemple des
munitions à guidage de précision des
systèmes et d'autres systèmes de pointes
conformes au nord de l'OTAN nous voyons
que sur le terrain ces systèmes on
change la donne et que les militaires
Uraniens savent manier utiliser ces
systèmes de manière efficace
et en grand ainsi les avancées sur le
champ de bataille il ne s'agit pas
simplement d'ajouter d'autres systèmes
ou des systèmes différents
faut-il avoir les munitions et le
carburant nécessaire pour exploiter ces
systèmes
donc la guerre se prolonge et la
logistique et l'approvisionnement
munitions et un carburant
pour exploiter les systèmes existants
tout cela devient de plus en plus
importants
se mettent à disposition des quantités
sans précédentes d'équipements parce que
nous avons l'obligation morale et
politique et
la victoire de l'Ukraine ne correspond
aussi à nos intérêts en matière de
sécurité
[Musique]
la Crimée a fait l'objet d'une annexion
illégale par la réussite
la Crimée fait partie de l'Ukraine
et l'OTAN a bien souligné que nous
n'allons jamais reconnaître l'annexion
illégale de la Crimée
et c'est bien la Russie qui a commencé
cette guerre c'est le président Poutine
qui a lancé cette guerre
revient pas sur les responsables de
l'attaque contre le pont l'Ukraine
correspondance là-dessus politique
merci beaucoup
je souhaite poser deux questions
rapidement
je reviens à ces questions de la défense
aérienne
à court terme dans les semaines qui
viennent est-ce que les alliés de l'OTAN
d'après vous disposent de la capacité de
tonnerre à Ukraine tous les systèmes de
défense aérienne revendiquées par qui
est-ce que vous attendez d'autres
annonces dans les jours qui viennent cet
effet et si l'on se tourne vers l'avenir
étant donné les pressions exercées sur
la scène politique intérieure de la
Russie est-ce que l'OTAN
réfléchit déjà la possibilité d'un
départ du pouvoir du président Poutine
avec la clé et la déstabilisation du
pays est-ce que vous y réfléchissez
ensemble
[Musique]
ont été faites par des alliés de l'OTAN
l'Allemagne et les États-Unis ils ont
annoncés pour leur fournir des systèmes
de défense aérienne plus avancées les
Allemands ont fait cette annonce hier et
nous saluons bien entendu cette annonce
les États-Unis quant à eux ont annoncé
les livraisons supplémentaires
à fournir des narcissons
il s'agit
d'un système dans des systèmes
particulièrement avancés reçu ces
derniers mois par l'Ukraine et il en
faut davantage bien entendu davantage de
munitions pour ces systèmes je salue
l'engagement la matière des alliés c'est
le système de défense aérienne font la
différence
bien des missiles entre un ont été
frappés neutralisées par des systèmes
Ukrainiens fournis par les alliés de
l'automne
tant que l'ensemble des missiles ne sont
pas neutralisés bien entendu il faut
davantage de ces défenses et c'est pour
cette raison que lors de la réunion
ministérielle de cette semaine demain
avec le ministre de la Défense Reznikov
nous aborderons cette question nous
voulons comprendre comment nous pouvons
acheminer ces systèmes le plus
rapidement possible nous pouvons aussi
entraîner les troupes offrir proposer
les pièces de rechange et renforcer en
effet ces systèmes de défense aérienne
vous aviez posé une deuxième question
je ne veux pas spéculer quand à la
situation politique interne en Russie
les analyses diverses et variées à
l'OTAN nous devons nous tenir prêt à
faire face à toutes les éventualités
pour ce qui est de l'Ukraine et nous
devons continuer à soutenir l'Ukraine
question
le mois prochain au Conseil de sécurité
il y aura une botte quant à l'extinction
prolongement de la mission de lieu en
Bosnie à ségovine il se pourrait que la
Russie impose son veto
êtes-vous préoccupations quant à la
préoccupée quand à la situation de
sécurité en Bosnie-Herzégovine et de
façon générale comment évaluer vous la
situation de sécurité dans les balcons
occidentaux merci
Réponse bien entendu nous suivons de
très près la situation dans les balcons
occidentaux plusieurs de nos alliés sont
des pays de la région et d'ailleurs le
largissement de l'OTAN ces dernières
années a été rendue possible grâce au
pays des balles occidentaux plus
récemment la moitié de 22 ans et le
Monténégro nous avons une longue
histoire nous avons réussi à mettre fin
à deux guerres ethniques notamment la
guerre en Bosnie-Herzégovine nous sommes
encore présents dans les balcons
occidentaux avec la mission
également le QG de l'auteur à Sarajevo
et nous appuyons l'opération de lieu
Altea je ne ferai pas ici de spéculation
quand au mandat peu fort Altea et à son
éventuel renouvellement ou non je dirais
cependant que c'est né dans l'intérêt de
personnes de ne pas voir ce mandat être
renouvelé en effet la présence de lieu
avec l'appui de l'OTAN études elle
permet de relever les défis auxquels la
Bosnie-Herzégovine est confrontée bien
entendu il y a bien des préoccupations
et bien des défis auxquels nous sommes
confrontés si nous devions réduire la
présence internationale sur le terrain
devait être mise à mal dans ce cas-là la
situation dans ce que compliquée une
dernière question une TV